dans la tête d'un chat on est en direct
on est très agité euh je vous cache pas
bon je sais
arrêtez arrêtez de faire faire du mytho
à moi je sais que vous attendez qu'une
seule chose c'est que je fasse le
débrief de l'émission d'hier je vais le
faire je vais vous montrer voulez que je
vous
dise tout ça c'est le débrive d'émission
d'hiver mais non tout ça c'est un livre
tout ça les gars tout ça ou quand même
il y a 10 points beaucoup de points ah
ouais quand même là tout ça tout ça les
gars vous inquiétez pas on va parler du
bateau 3 millions 3Li tu vu qu'il y en a
qui se plignit de la
couleur on le catalogue ensemble on va
voir ce qu'on peut faire non mais sans
rigoler non mais franchement on va
parler de tout on va parler de tout j'ai
qu'une envie moi en plus j'ai vérité je
vous dis franchement j'ai envie de faire
que ça aujourd'hui oui d'autes ils me
disent regardez ils me disent des trucs
on découvre les photos des mil B de
qu'est j'en a à [__] déjà vu qu j'en a
à [__] qu j'en a à [__] faire quoi
que quand
même on va le faire ça on va le faire
pour nous détendre avant hein c'est bien
tu vois en chemia en chemia tu vois ou
pas en fricass en brique en minina tu
vois ou pas bon les chériis donc c'est
PASF ouvert à tous avec Baba on a plein
de trucs à faire vous avez vu j'ai tout
ça à faire dans un lapse de temps très
court pour vous dire et puis après il y
a le sang de la vigne ça va être une
autre histoire là l'histoire aujourd'hui
incroyable c'est quoi l'histoire un gars
qui a perdu un bouchon dans chez
lui un bouchon de liège il appelle de
partout ça dure 1 heure et de vous allez
voir à la fin on se rend compte qu'il
est dans un endroit où vraiment on ne se
doutait pas du tout et pour ceux qui me
diront dans son cul c'est vraiment pas
sympa non non mais c'est vrai on verra
ça dans un instant vous verraz il y a
l'indique de la rédaque également Sacha
el Baze ou et oui et et j'ai connu Sacha
Baz était comme ça
[Rires]
c'est fou c'est
fou et paka tu es content d'être là oui
très contente pe rapper ce que tu fais
dans la vie alors je suis influenceuse
ouais c'est ça oui TikTok tout ça
tuinfluence tuinfluence les jeunes ouais
les jeunes don je suis le côté jeune de
tu as pas envie d'influencer Daniel un
peu ah si pourquoi pas franchement on a
bien sympathisé hein elle arrive pas
elle arrive ma copine maintenant non
c'est vrai oui alors franchement si vous
faites une soirée
ensemble êre m'appelez pas hein
c'est le choc des cultures là c'est
quand même même des civilisations hein
non mais là franchement c'est vrai
voulez pas danser un petit peu toutes
les deux là oh non non non allez-y
[Applaudissements]
sympath vous
êtes va pas [__] le toboggan c'est
jeune c'est pas france télé qui va me le
payer ça en fait j'ai une danse ouis je
t'explique ouais non mais je m'en fous
un peu ah non non mais vas-y aends t'end
à toi alors j'ai une danse non
t'inquiète j'ai une danse spéciale à moi
faut faire comme ça voà et tu danses oui
mais excuse-moi pourquoi to on dirait
que tu as des asticos dans le flip mais
elle elle fa non mais sans déconner non
mais elle mettait mettait un
son vas-y Daniel vas-y vas-y alle prê
ou vasy
e regarde regarde regarde là-bas regarde
là-bas ah oui je peux pas me regarder il
y a un me pas
ou c'est bien très mais c'est c'est bon
allez allez allez rentrez chez
vous allez rentrez allez rentrez chez
vous rentrez chez vous merci euh c'est
pas nul non c'est pas n tu manqué un peu
de génér vous avez quel âge pa moi 24 24
tu te rends compte tu te rends compte tu
as 200 ans de
moin ans de moins c'est fou elle a 224
elle non mais sans déconner elle se fait
flasher sur l'autoroute à cause de son
âge mais sent bien elle est fraîche tu
ah ouais
ah sortir avec elle tu as pas un cum
pour elle euh ben un plus jeune quel âge
ah oui bah la vingtaine ah soy
raisonnable frèreouis tu vas pas lui
mettre un mec de 20 ans non maisc comme
ça c'est la sugar Momy ouais mais là
c'est plus sugar m là c'est elle aime
les hommes murs plutôt ah ouais tu as
pas des mecs plus vieux 30 en plus il
faut des mecs vers
70 il faut du jeune du peps toi tu crois
ah non non non non je te dis non en tout
cas commencez à vous côtoyer d'accord
hein parlez-vous et je ferai un speed
deting ouais c'est pas mal bon ben merci
c'est vrai qu'on parle beaucoup de tes
pieds oui pourquoi il paraît qu'ils sont
bah ils sont un peu mal formés quoi
c'est vrai ah ouais merde je savais pas
mais c'est quelqu'un qui m'a dit ça ah
ouais c'est qui comment il sa oui
comment un gars m'a dit mais quel gars
je vous jure que c'est vrai et tu veux
que je te dise un gars der FO on était
dans la voiture il m'a dit ouais tu as
vu on les pieds de palska je j'ai déjà
vu mais j'ai jamais montré ses pieds il
rien à [__] c'est Raymon qui vous a
dit ça
ça y est il est dans la elle es
fétichiste pas du tout j'ai remarqué
qu'elle avait des bottes avec un Caden
donc elle doit tenir elle doit tenir à
ses pieds elle doit faire attention les
pieds sont verrouillés mais c'est pas
moi du tout tu sais c ça critique mais
tu sais que j'ai vendu mes pieds à 20000
€ non j c'est vrai j'ai une phot de M pi
200000 € mais comment tu fais pour
marcher
alors maisi tuas vendu une photo de tes
pied à 20000 boules mais arrête je te
jure mais ils sont vraiment ils sont ils
sont normaux mais bon bah je te les
montrerai après non t'emmerd pas pour
20000 € 20000 € parce qu'ils sont très
bizarres ou parce qu'ils sont bah en
fait ils sont un peu comme ça écartés
ah ouais ouais ah ouais en araignée en
araignée mais je vou les montrer à tous
Après qu'est-ce que tu veux avec tes
pieds hein par contre si un jour tu te
maries faut pas fa pas que ton mec faut
vraiment qu'il demande Ta main pas ton
pied
quoi tu demande pour qui à ton c'est
vrai que c'est un peu chelou et on est
sorti ensemble samedi soir
c'est très sympa très sympa j'ai
découvert un autre cyil alors calme ah
oui justement ah ou non mais c'est ça ça
m'a surpris je TR mais calme distingué
hyper
avant franement franchement la classe
arrivé claque on a bien mangé il nous a
régalé il dansait mais discret voilà les
gens voulaient prendre des selfies
prenent des selfies hMPA il a payé je
suis sûr il a payé il a payé
nous il nous a invité cétait c'était
junkleem une super soirée clorent soit
plus riche que moi je les ai quand même
invité mais on se rattrape on se
rattrape dimanche dimanche dimanche
dimanche je suis invité chez eux ou
dimanche le match ensemble ouais ah oua
on va regarder un match de foot le HAV
Marseille entre couilles
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
psgg mais arrête avec ou parce que la
première question qu' m'a demandé
Laurent quand il est arrivé il m'a dit
mais dis-moi Raymon c'est ton mec tu dis
ah
non Laurent Laurent non tu fais fausse
route là mon Lolo hein non mais c'est
vrai mais il a kiffé il dansait et tout
franchement il et je voudrais dire et je
le redis une fois de plus je vous je dis
quand j'aime et j'aime pas je leaurais
dit vraiment laurentier c'est un amour
vraiment c'est vraiment un mec c'est un
un des un des vraiment des gabiens de la
télévision et vraiment j'aime beaucoup
ce garçon il le sait et c'est vraiment
c'est c'est une bombe il est sympathique
il rigole par hier soir il était mort de
R regard dans la télé à partir de 23h
c'est quoi l'appeler pour savoir ce
qu'il en pense ceil en a pensé aussi
tout à l'heure de
malz je sais pas essay mais je crois
qu'il a un tournage de de grosse tête là
en provinceourage de gros t à 19h1 à mon
avis il un am surtout il est parti
vers mais ESS essaye
appème il va te dire ce qu'il en a pensé
tu vas pas être tu vas ça plaisir tu vas
nous le dire de toute façon vous avez
fait l'amour
après pendant pendant je l'ai dit Hervé
est avec nous il a 47 ans il habite à
Saint- maaurice exactement tu bah tu on
est très content que sois là tu es très
beau gosse ah bah c'est gentil en tout
cas moi je suis très heureux d'être avec
vous vraiment ben nous aussi on est tu
tu as vu hier le le bail oui je l'ai vu
donc tu pouras en parler avec nous aussi
volontiers j'ai quelque chose à dire
après ex i si tu dis ce ah mais je dir
exactement P pour leur faire plaisir tu
diras bien que en log je t'ai vu avant
et je t'ai dis ce qu'il fallait dire ce
soir tout à
faitit comme tout monde j'ai bien le
petit billet vraiment t'inqu
décrédibiliser France Télévision sont
des amis j'ai encore des productions
avant de la barre